welcome back to another installment of
Christmas with me
eart um really happy about the reception
of the first video in this series and
I'm very excited to be reading another
one of me Art's beautiful Christmas
sermons for you on this um second week
of the Advent season in in preparation
for Christmas
I realized that even again I'm I'm
recording this on the Sunday but again
I'm probably not going to be releasing
it on the Sunday because today I am
putting out a video about uh Luchia St
Lucy's day with you know collaboration
with my friend Angela and so I'm
probably going to be
waiting I'm going to wait with this eart
video until maybe tomorrow or something
so it doesn't interfere with with that
other video um but nonetheless very
excited to be here again and I hope you
are as well as well um I'm not going to
introduce eart in the same way that I
did before this time I think if you want
a a thorough introduction to eart and
his thought then you can either just
watch my quick summary in the beginning
of the first video in this series or go
watch my full like 45 minute video on on
eart that I did a few years ago and
there will be links to that in the
description and so on um first of all uh
by now the traditional lighting of the
candles I'm going to do it once more
hopefully it'll go as smoothly as last
time um this time as well and yes we I'm
already I would lit this this morning
because I'm not going to be wasting
candles um here we
go I did
it welcome once again today we're going
to be reading the second
sermon the second sermon is um a bit
more complex it goes more into that um
theme of the birth of the word in the
soul the birth of the sun and the Soul
what that means and that theme of
Unknowing um which is what leads to that
birth of the Soul or the experience of
that birth in the soul uh a little more
deeply in this one which also makes it a
little more uh difficult a little harder
to to sort of um
uh to to grasp fully um but I think we
can make it through it uh the consensus
for the last video seems to have been
that you want me to keep commenting as
we go so I'm going to keep doing that
although I don't think I will have as
many comments this time partly because
um well we covered a lot of it already
last time there might be some repetition
of course but also because it's more
difficult so even I'm sometimes a little
bit you know confused by what's being
said so uh but we're going to do our
best to to sort of comment where where
we can and and we'll we'll sort of get
through it together it's not I'm I'm
like building it up as if it's something
really really difficult it's not that
difficult but it's certainly uh more
dense than the last one um the last one
was a bit more broadly about you know
this kind of knowledge you know the
mystical knowledge and very sort of
covered a lot of a lot of the bases of
Art's thought this one goes more deeply
into that particular aspect um that is
at the center of of Christmas for E
which is the birth of the son both in
eternity in the in the ground of of the
father or sorry the ground of of God the
grun but also of course in the ground of
the Soul because once again the ground
of God and the ground of the soul is one
on the same ground and he's going to be
talking a bit more about that in
particular here there's going to be some
nuancing and uh yeah we'll discuss that
as we go um again we're going to be
using um the translations of Maurice o
Conor Walsh which I think is is a very
competent and beautiful translation this
this book The the complete mystical
works of me eart is is is a book that I
highly recommend for anyone who's
interested in in this really fascinating
Dominican
philosopher SL Mystic
Theologian so we're going to get right
into
it this is the second sermon of my ech
Parts series of sermons during the
Christmas
season the Bible verse in question this
time is Matthew 2 verse
2 where is he who is born King of the
Jews now observe as regards this birth
where it takes place where is he who is
born now I say as I have often said
before that this eternal birth occurs in
the soul precisely as it does in
eternity
no more and no less for it is one birth
and this birth occurs in the essence and
ground of the Soul right so here he
summarizes that whole idea right because
the sun is being born in the in the
ground of God and the and the and the
godhead and because the ground is one
that means that this birth is taking
place in the soul eternally at all times
in the Eternal
present now certain questions arise
first first of all since God is in all
things as intelligence and is more truly
in them than they are in themselves and
more naturally and since wherever God is
there he must work knowing himself and
speaking his word in what special
respects then is the soul better fitted
for this Divine operation than are other
rational creatures in which God also is
pay attention to the
explanation God is in all things as
being as AC activ ity as power but he's
in the soul alone for though
every creature is a vestage of God the
soul is the natural image of God this
image must be adorned and perfected in
this birth no creature but the soul
alone is receptive to this act this
birth indeed such Perfection as enters
the soul whether it be divine undivided
light Grace or Bliss must enter the soul
through this birth and in no other way
just await this birth within you and you
shall experience all good and all
comfort all happiness all being and all
truth if you miss it you will miss all
good and
blessedness
so he brings up this
idea that not only is the ground of God
and the ground of of of the Soul one and
the same ground but God is some
also um the ground of everything God is
in all things as being he says God is
being according to eart there is no
being aside from God um God is the very
concept of being and thus the being any
any any being that we experience in the
world that is god um although the
creatures the the things of this world
the multiplicity they are actually
nothingness and so they are both when we
see all these things around us it is
both God and not God at the same time in
some mysterious way and we can
understand this primarily
through um this
idea um he sort of adds this this little
um phrase at the end of many of these
sayings in that he would say my for
example say me my being is God in so far
as it is being and that's an important
section there at the end my knowledge or
my wisdom is God in so far as it is
knowledge so all these attributes being
Oneness intelligence whatever it is all
these actually only truly belong to God
and this is a kind of almost a platonic
kind of thing right um in that my being
there is only God's being so any being
that I have that's actually God's being
that's God but only in so far as it is
being I am not God in my creatureliness
if you know what I'm saying I'm not God
in this uh body in this Multiplicity uh
you know although you know there are
that's complicated too because God is
the ground of of everything but but in
terms of my being I am God in so far as
I am
being and and this is a very nuanced
thing but it's very it's very important
in order to understand eart properly um
for example so we don't understand him
as a pantheist or something like that he
is not equating the world of
Multiplicity in it to in its totality
with God in a sort of direct way um um
not all of all of this those candles me
it's nothing it's
nothingness but in some way it's also
being because it exists but that that
existence that being is God in so far as
it is being okay so it it it gets
complicated but I hope you can sort of
follow what I'm saying um so that's a
bit of what he's saying
here um that everything everything's all
things their being is God and God is in
all things in a certain sense in that
sense but he's also saying that the soul
and I understand this as meaning the
soul of the human being in particular is
the only place that is sort of um
receptive of this birth of the word in a
direct sense so and and he will continue
this this this theme of that the human
being is still of course somewhat unique
the soul of human being is unique in
creation um and he's going to get into
why that is but um that's that's what
he's saying here
um no creature but the soul is the soul
alone is receptable receptive to this
act to this birth and so he's also
saying here what we said in the last
video that this birth of the sun which
this whole sermon and all of the
Christmas season is about is a sort of
is is the phrase that refers to the
utmost mystical experience right of this
kind of Union with God of being
overwhelmed with this unity and this all
of this unknowing knowledge it all is
represented by this this theme of of the
birth of the son that was a long this
was a long comment on just those first
couple of of of paragraphs but um I
think that's important to keep in mind
so let's let's continue
here whatever comes to you in that will
bring you pure being and stability but
whatever you seek or cleave to apart
from this will perish take it how you
will and where you will all will perish
this alone gives being all else perishes
everything but God will perish
ultimately is what he's saying here so
the only thing that we can seek that
will not perish that will not sort of
Escape our grasp and just um you know
like in in Ecclesiastes everything is
just mist or smoke everything is uh um I
can't remember the translation they're
using but everything is is um empty we
can never we can never grasp anything
it's like smoke um except for God and
that is the true knowledge that we can
have this alone gives being all else
perishes but in this birth you will
share in the Divine influx and all its
gifts you cannot be received by
creatures in which God's image is not
found for the Soul's image app pertains
especially to this eternal birth which
happens truly and especially in the soul
being begotten of the father in The
Soul's ground and innermost recesses
into which no image ever shun nor Soul
power
peeped the second question is since this
work of birth occurs in the essence and
ground of the Soul then it happens just
as much in a sinner as in a saint so
what Grace or good is there in it for me
for the ground of nature is the same in
both in fact even those in Hell retain
their nobility of nature eternally so a
good question here right at least to a
Christian if if this if this birth take
place in in the soul
if this the soul and the ground is one
in this sense that means that this is
happening in all of us even sinner as
much as a saint so and that can become a
theological question right how like
what's the use then of being a saint if
if this is happening to everyone right
so that opens up for a lot of U maybe
confusion or or antom anti nominalism
for example so he's going to try to
address that now note the answer
it is a property of this birth that it
always comes with fresh Light it always
brings a great light to the soul for it
is the nature of good to diffuse itself
wherever it is in this birth God streams
into the soul in such abundance of light
so flooding the essence and ground of
the soul that it runs over and floods
into the powers and into the outward man
thus it befell Paul when on his journey
God touched him with his light and spoke
to him a reflection of the light shun
outwardly so that His companion saw it
surrounding Paul like the blessed in
heaven the superfluity of light in the
ground of the Soul Wells over into the
body which is filled with Radiance no
sinner can receive this light nor is he
worthy to being full of sin and
wickedness which is called Darkness
therefore it says the darkness shall
neither receive nor comprehend the light
that is because the paths by which the
light would enter are choked and
obstructed with guile and darkness for
light and darkness cannot coexist or God
and creatures if God shall enter the
creatures must simultaneously go
out a man is fully aware of this light
directly he turns to God a light begins
to gleam and glow within him giving him
to understand what to do and what to
leave undone with much true guidance in
regards to things of which before he
knew or understood
nothing so he's
comparing um he's using a metaphor of
light here and and eard is pretty
neoplatonist in a lot of his thinking
and I think it shows here um in that
he's comparing God versus whatever is
not God with light and darkness right
this God pours pours his light into the
soul um or the soul is receptive to that
light when it sort of empties itself of
all things then it is receptive to the
light of God and he also seems to say
that it somehow sort of flows over into
the powers of the body too that so for a
saint that is truly receptive to that
light and there's nothing obstructing
that light through sinning for example
then that light can sort of uh flow over
into their actions and then and their
powers and and into their behavior as
well whereas for a sinner there's a
bunch of just clogging like Darkness
like stuff in the way so that the light
cannot get there this reminds me of this
newon idea uh which a lot of people
including I think eart and a lot of
people within the abrahamic religions
adapt as a sort of solution for the
problem of evil right um if God creates
all things and even in some these
theologies if God sort of if everything
is a sort of reflection of God or or a
sort of manifestation of God then how do
we explain evil but regardless of how we
see that like evil is always going to be
a problem according to to to a lot of
people how come there is evil in in the
world if a good God created this world
and so the neoplatonist and and by
following them a lot of these Christian
Muslim Jewish theologians answer that
with this kind of
um this philosophy of of negation or
metaphysic metaphysics of negation
that evil is the absence of God in the
same way or absence of being which is
God existence in the same way that
darkness is just the absence of light or
or or or cold is just the absence of
heat right so evil just like Darkness
does not have any kind of existence of
its own it's it's a lacking it's a
lacking of being or a lacking of of God
in a neoplatonic language is the lacking
of the one it's a sort of opposite of
the one the opposite of being uh that is
what evil is and it seems like he's
using that kind of language here where
God pours his light forth but but
sinning and evil is sort of represented
by the darkness which is the absence of
that
light so we
continue where do you know this from and
in what way just pay attention your
heart is often moved and turned away
from the
world how could that be but by this
illumination it is so charming and
delightful that you become wary of all
things that are not God or Gods it draws
you to God and you become aware of many
a prompting to do good though ignorant
of whence it comes this inward
inclination is in no way due to
creatures or their bidding for What
creatures direct or effect always comes
from without but by this work it is only
the ground of the soul that is stirred
and the Freer you keep yourself the more
light truth and discernment you will
find thus no man ever went astray for
any other reason than that he first
departed from this
and then sought too much to cling to
outward
things St Augustine says there are many
who sought light and truth but only
outside where it was not to be found
finally they go out so far that they
never get back home or find their way in
again thus they have not found the truth
for truth is within in the ground and
not without so he who would see the
light to discern all truth let him watch
and become aware of this birth within in
the ground
then all his powers will be illuminated
and the outer man as well for as soon as
God inwardly stirs the ground with truth
its light darts into his powers and that
man knows a times more than anyone could
teach him as the prophet says I have
gained greater understanding than all
who ever taught
me you see then because this light
cannot shine or lighten in Sinners this
is why this birth cannot possibly occur
in them this birth cannot Co exist with
the darkness of sin even though it takes
place not in the powers but in the
essence and ground of the
Soul so when you when you when you
experience this birth when you when you
come to this Union um that also of
course affects your outward actions and
your and your and your behavior and so
on the powers as he calls them which is
the sort of outward everything that is
not in the kind of complete past
passivity of the Soul that's the powers
the soul acting
outwardly um and which is why for
example we discussed last time you know
a person who has become completely
United to God
cannot cannot sin in a certain sense
because he is sort of United to God's
Will and that light sort of pours forth
into his powers into his behavior from
being born in in the
soul this is how I read
this the question arises since God the
father gives birth only in the essence
and ground of the soul and not in the
Powers what concern is it of theirs how
do they help just by being Idol and
taking a rest what is the use since this
birth does not take place in the powers
a good question listen well with the
explanation so we this um I hope I'm not
cutting off too much here but again I'm
going back to that idea like but um if
this take place beyond the powers beyond
anything that we do outwardly then what
does it matter what we do outwardly if
it's if it's taking place in the soul
you know in any way or if it's taking
place in the soul regardless then why
should we pray why should we all do all
these things if this is this is
happening to us whether we like it or
not um so he's going to try to explain
this here every creature Works towards
some
end the end is always the first in
intention but the last in
execution thus too God in all his Works
has has a Most Blessed end in view
namely himself to bring the soul and all
our powers into that end himself for
this all God's works are wrought for
this the father Bears his son in the
soul so that all the powers of the Soul
shall come to this he lies in wait for
all that the soul contains bidding all
to this Feast at his
court but the soul is scattered abroad
among our powers and dissipated in the
action of each the power of sight in the
eye the power of hearing in the ear the
power of tasting in the tongue thus her
ability to work inwardly is enfeebled
for a scattered power is
imperfect so for her inward work to be
effective she must call in all her
powers and gather them together from the
diversity of things to a single inward
activity St Augustine says that the soul
is rather where she loves than where she
gives life to the body for example there
was once a pagan master who was devoted
to an art that of mathematics to which
he had devoted all his powers he was
sitting by the Embers making
calculations and practicing his art when
a man came along who drew a sword and
not knowing that it was the master said
quick tell me your name or I'll kill you
the master was too absorbed to see or
hear the foe or to catch what he said he
was unable to utter a word even to say
my name is so and so and so the enemy
having cried out several times and got
no answer cut off his head and this was
to acquire a mere Natural Science how
much more then should we withdraw from
all things in order to concentrate all
our powers on perceiving and knowing the
one infinite uncreated Eternal truth to
this end then assemble all your powers
all your senses your entire mind and
memory direct them into the ground where
your treasure lies
buried but if this is to happen realize
that you must drop all other works you
must come to an unknowing if you would
find
it so all the upward Powers you need to
sort of all your outward actions where
whether it's a senses or thinking or
whatever all that needs to be shut off
your whole being needs to be focused
completely inwardly on this one single
thing which is to penetrate into that
ground to to to break through into the
ground where everything is Unified in a
certain sense
and this is through unknowing we talked
about this last time it's not it's not
any kind of knowing you don't know this
intellectually actually this is like
pseudo dnus says it's a way of
Unknowing of of of just detaching from
all kinds of knowing in terms of knowing
like conceptual knowing images or ideas
or thoughts uh until you know nothing
until you're completely silent nothing
passive that is when you can experience
the true knowing which is the Union of
the
ground the question arises would it not
be more valuable for each power to keep
to its own task none hindering the
others in their work nor God in his
might there not be in me a manner of
creaturely knowing that is not a
hindrance just as God knows all things
without hindrance and so too the blessed
in heaven that is a good question not
the
explanation the Blessed see God in a
single image and in that image they
discern all things things God too sees
himself thus perceiving all things in
himself he need not turn from one thing
to another as we do suppose in this life
we always had a mirror before us in
which we saw all things at a glance and
recognize them in a single image then
neither action nor knowledge would be
any hindrance to us but we have to turn
from one thing to another and so we can
only attend to one thing at the expense
of
another for the soul is so firmly atted
attached to the powers that she has to
flow with them wherever they flow
because in every task they perform the
soul must be present and attentive or
they could not work at all if she is
dissipated by attending to outward act
this is bound to weaken her inward
work for at this birth God needs and
must have a vacant free and unencumbered
soul containing nothing but himself
alone and which looks to nothing and
nobody but him and to this Christ says
whoever loves anything but me whoever
loves father and mother or many other
things is not worthy of me I did not
come upon Earth to bring peace but a
sword to cut away all things to part you
from sister brother Mother child and
friend that in truth are your
foes for whatever is familiar to you is
your foe if your eye wants to see all
things and your ear to hear all things
and your heart to remember all things
then indeed your soul would be
dissipated in all these
things accordingly a master says to
achieve an interior act a man must
collect all his powers as if into a
corner of his soul where hiding away
from all images and forms he can get to
work here he must come to a forgetting
and an
unknowing there must be a Stillness and
a silence for this word to make itself
heard we cannot serve this word better
than in Stillness and in silence
there we can hear it and there too we
will understand it right in the
unknowing to him who knows nothing it
appears and reveals itself this is a
very powerful statement of ticism and
and particular of Unknowing this
returning theme in aart and in cus for
example um and we've already we've
already sort of been through that so we
don't need to to to to repeat that but I
think this section here we just read is
a beautiful and very clear sort of
explanation of what's going on with that
particular
theme we
continue another question arises you
might say sir you place all our
Salvation in
ignorance this sounds like a lack God
made man to know as the prophet says
Lord make them know where there is
ignorance there is a lack something is
missing a man is brutish an ape a fool
remains so long as he is ignorant this
is a good question I've gotten this
question a lot too when I talk about
this idea of Unknowing that this seems
kind of counterintuitive like why would
you want to unknow things like this
sounds like he's he's um exalting
ignorance and this is actually not what
aard is saying or
pseudois um which he will explain in the
in the following words so I should just
be quiet and let a speak for himself he
says Ah but here we must come to to a
transformed
knowledge and this unknowing must not
come from ignorance but rather from
knowing we must get to this
unknowing then we shall become knowing
with Divine knowing and our unknowing
will be ennobled and adorned with
Supernatural knowing and through holding
ourselves passive in this we are more
perfect than if we were
active interesting right so unknowing is
not ignorance to get to unknowing you
must first know things so that you can
then can know that you are to
unlearn but but but this unknowing is a
different unknowing or not knowing than
the not knowing you had before when you
like legitimately didn't know anything
right instead it's a kind of informed
like he says he calls it a transformed
knowledge a
knowledge a knowledge Beyond
knowledge so it's not an ignorance it's
it's a hyper and again go back to pudus
I think he uses um the word heer uh to
to just um which is a brilliant move uh
it's it's sort of hyper knowledge in
that it is in that it is a kind of
knowledge that is is more true knowledge
than than any other knowledge but which
is also the reason why it's sort of
Beyond knowledge why it's
unknowing and then he continues he says
that is why one master declares that the
sense of hearing is nobler than that of
sight for we learn more wisdom by
hearing than by seeing and in it live
the more wisely and I think this is
referring to hertis right because I want
to say that there's a
section uh among the fragments of herius
where he sort of seems
to um allude to the idea that that
hearing is superior to seeing in some
way I could be wrong but I I that that
sounds like like a heraclitus thing uh
yes we hear of a pagan master who Lay
Dying his disciples discussed in his
presence some Noble arts and dying
though he was he lifted up his head to
listen saying oh let me learn this art
now that I may rejoice in it
forever hearing draws in more but seeing
rather leads outward the very Act of
seeing does this therefore in eternal
life we shall rejoice far more in our
power of hearing than in that of sight
for the act of hearing is for the act of
hearing the Eternal Word is within me
but the act of seeing Goes Forth from me
in hearing I am passive but in seeing I
am
active um and I can't help here but see
um a kind of outdated um science of
Optics that that eart is s of operating
by um so before there were different
theories of course but but by the Middle
Ages the general idea was that the way
we see is not that the eyes take in
things from from take in light and
things from outside um and then then
sort of give that information to the
brain but rather that the eyes somehow
sort of shoot out these beams um that
make us see things so the things that
the eyes sort of shoot out um and hits
that's what we see that was that was the
the old sort of classic idea of of how
seeing Works uh but with people like I
haam in in the Islamic hit World um he
you know he didn't come up with this
idea of course but but he was very
important in formulating this idea of
the opposite right that seeing is
actually things coming not these things
going up from the eyes and and hitting
things but rather things coming in from
outside so light going into the eyes and
making us see things so eart here is is
alluding to the idea that seeing is
active whereas hearing is passive and it
seems to me that this is because eart
might be um I think I the ideas ofam who
seems to also sort of prove this idea of
light coming in rather than going out um
haam is often seen as a sort of father
of the scientific method and he did live
before that before eart but I don't
think his ideas of Optics might have
been
accepted but I could be wrong but it
seems like eard is operating from this
older idea of the eyes being active
rather than passive because we know that
the eyes take in light which makes them
passive so this this this section seems
a bit outdated perhaps in that sense but
we can still sort of try to see what
he's saying here in that it is the
passivity that is superior because
and this go this connects to his idea of
Unknowing that is when we know nothing
when we are passive and completely
silent that is when
God becomes apparent to us so the the
recurring um theme across these um
sermons we continue again but our Bliss
lies not in our activity but in being
passive to God for just as God is more
excellent than creatures by so much is
God's Works more excellent than mine it
was from his immeasurable able love that
God set our happiness in suffering for
we undergo more than we act and receive
incomparably more than we give and each
gift that we receive prepares us to
receive yet another gift you need a
greater one and every Divine gift
further increases our receptivity and
the desire to receive something yet
higher and greater therefore some
teachers say that is in this respect the
soul is commensurate with God for just
as God is boundless in giving so to the
soul is boundless in receiving or
conceiving and just as God is omnipotent
to act so too the soul is no less
profound to suffer and thus she is
transformed with God and in God God must
act and the Soul must suffer he must
know and love himself in her she must
know with his knowledge and love with
his love and thus she is far more with
what is his than with her own and so to
her Bliss is more dependent on his
action than on her own
the peoples of St dianus asked him why
Timothy surpassed them all in Perfection
dianus replied Timothy is a Gods
suffering man whoever is expert at this
could outstrip all men so so he loves
with his love he knows with his
knowledge so as we said in the beginning
all these attributes actually belong to
God um there are sometimes called the
transcendentals and there there are a
couple of them like being Oneness I
think intelligence is one of them too um
these actually belong to God and so when
we
um love at least especially when we're
United to God we reach the state when we
love we love with God's love or we know
with God's knowledge is what he's saying
here so in this way your unknowing is
not a lack but your Chief Perfection and
you're suffering your highest activity
and so in this way you must cast aside
all your deeds and silence your
faculties if you really wish to
experience this birth in you if you
would find the newborn king you must
outstrip and abandon all else you might
find that we may outstrip and cast
behind us all things unpleasing to the
newborn king may he help us who became a
human child in order that we might
become the children of God
Amen so that was the second sermon like
I said a bit more involved a bit more
subtle and a bit more um dense perhaps
difficult but I think eart is comparably
pretty clear in his language that is one
of the things I lack about him he can
sometimes be pretty difficult but um
compared to other Mystics he he often
comes off as
very easier to understand especially
these German um sermons uh reading his
Latin Scholastic works is maybe a
different thing but in these sermons in
German I think he comes off as as very
clear because he's using his native
language he's sort of um he's speaking
maybe not in this case but he's often
speaking to the general people you know
and so he expresses these ideas in a in
very profound ways in these sermons and
and uh and this sermon in particular as
we saw goes more in depth into that idea
of of the birth of the word and and the
idea of Unknowing and how these connect
with each other and so I think it's a
really really beautiful Sermon Just Like
the first one this was a sermon that I
read a few years ago so there's always a
video of this sermon which is just me
reading through it without any breaks or
anything and some music behind it so if
you want to just experience it in that
way then you can check out that all
video uh but I hope you enjoyed this
more
involved reading of this second
sermon um so yeah that was that was this
week's Christmas with my eart I hope you
you could take something away from from
this sermon
um again you don't have to be Christian
or or follow his theology but there are
certain things that we can sort of get
inspired by uh if anything just by his
amazing way with words and very
beautiful way of expressing some of the
sort of core aspects of reality I think
I think there is a lot of Beauty in
that um and like I said last time I hope
the the the holiday season or the the
the the December season is treating you
well there's there's a lot going on of
course right now it's the winter solers
um it's it's hanuka it's it's um you
know Christmas is coming up so it's a
special time for a lot of people and so
I hope uh the time is is Meaningful and
beautiful for you uh we're having a good
time here in the darkness of Sweden we
have Lucia or St Lucy coming up in just
a couple of days which is a very
fascinating kind of strange um holiday
that's very popular in particular here
in Scandinavia um and kind of nowhere
else except maybe Italy to some degree
so um and I just put a put out a video
today as of recording this about that so
you can check that out um but other than
that again I hope you enjoyed this
reading I hope this season is positive
or at least meaningful to you and I hope
you're looking forward to as much as I
am next week reading uh next week's
reading of the third sermon so until
then I hope your week is filled with
light and meaning and I will see you in
the next
[Music]
video